In the office of Paul’s editor, we see cover
art for several Misery books.
This is the book series that made him famous,
and caused his self proclaimed number one
fan to keep him prisoner after he breaks his
legs.
This one is a French version of Misery’s
Love, one of the four Misery books specifically
mentioned in the novel by Stephen King.
Misery’s Quest is another, and we can see
that cover right here.
The first Misery book is called The Adventures
of Misery Chastain in the movie,
it’s a little
easier to see later on in the film.
We also get a look at the cover of the
original finale of the Misery series, Misery’s
Child.
Annie would force Paul to write a sequel to
Misery’s Child, which would be known as
Misery’s Return, and in the pages we see
him writing, there are some easter eggs you
might have missed, stick around to the end
of this video to hear about them.
Welcome to Things You Missed.
Today I’m covering the 1990 film adaptation
of Stephen King’s novel Misery.
If you haven’t figured that out already,
that’s what we’re doing today.
King was not really all that down to sell
the movie rights to Misery at first, which
I find kind of ironic because the main character
kind of considers himself a sell-out, but
according to Mental Floss he ended up changing
his mind because he liked what director Rob
Reiner did in adapting his novella, The Body,
into the movie known as Stand by Me; which
is a non-horror movie so I probably won’t
cover it on my channel, but there is one scene
that’s truly horrifying.
"Leaches!"
*screaming*
"Get 'em off!"
"Get 'em off me!"
Anyway… let’s get back to Misery.
The movie opens with Paul finishing up his
next novel.
He’s finally free of making Misery books
after killing the character in the previous
one, so he’s moved onto something more serious.
We can see some of the text on the final page
of this book.
It reads:
“‘I better not take that for granted anymore,’
he told himself.
Breathing might not seem like much, but without
it, what else was there…?”
This is Paul not practicing what he preaches,
not yet at least, because at the end of the
movie, he’ll eventually admit that he was
taking his life for granted before his experience
with Annie Wilkes.
“In some way, Annie Wilkes… that whole
experience… helped me.”
Annie tries to make him burn this book later
on, and in doing so, we get a glimpse of the
first page.
But it actually looks more like an essay about
teen movies, and mentioned Say Anything, Risky
Business, The Graduate and Fast Times At Ridgemont
High.
After finishing this new book, Paul leaves
the hotel he was writing it at and his car
has a VKY 722 license plate, which is a common
plate seen in a lot of movies, like The Freshman,
Shaft and The Wolf of Wall Street, there are
probably others, I guess this is like the
Wilhelm Scream of license plates.
Just before heading off, he throws a snowball
at a tree, which may be a small nod to the
fact that he played High School baseball in
the novel, where he supposedly couldn’t
hit a curve.
And I wouldn’t be Emo Abraham Lincoln if
i didn’t mention this part.
“I was a writer then.”
“You’re still a writer.”
“I haven’t been a writer since I got in
the Misery business.”
“I’m in the business of Misery, let’s
take it from the top.”
Earlier I mentioned that we get to see the
cover art of Misery’s Child in the film,
and when we see it later, you’ll also notice
the publisher is Viking Press, who in real
life at the time, published several Stephen
King novels such as The Dead Zone, Firestarter,
Cujo, Christine, The Talisman, The Eyes of
the Dragon, IT and course: Misery.
When Paul wakes up in Annie’s house after
the crash, she tells him where he is.
“We’re just outside Silver Creek.”
This is changed from the fictional town of
Sidewinder, Colorado in the book.
Silver Creek is a real town, in fact, it was
a former mining town, which could be a clue
about the old miner’s practice of hobbling
their workers; a tactic that Annie uses on
her prisoner.
There are also references to mining in some
of the newspapers seen on screen.
Usually in Things You Missed, whenever there
are newspapers, there are easter eggs -- mainly
consisting of the art department of the movie
trying to sneak their names in there as the
author of an article or something.
There’s not a whole lot of that in Misery
though, and I think it’s because many of
the articles are just copied from real life
local newspapers in Nye County, Nevada where
the movie was filmed.
It actually shows up a couple times if you
pay close attention, even though the setting
of the movie is part of Clear Creek County,
in Colorado.
The only crew reference easter egg I found
in the many newspapers that appear in Misery
is in the article about Annie being arrested
after the death of several babies in her maternity
ward, where it states her lawyer is named
Steven Popelka, who is likely a relative of
Joseph Popelka, a production assistant.
Outside of the newspapers, there’s also
a sticky note in the Police Chief’s office
that says “call Carlsen”, a reference
to Charles Carlsen, the prop maker slash set dresser.
And that is it!
So let’s go back to Annie’s house, because
it’s breakfast time.
“I made you my specialty!
Scrambled eggs a la Wilkes.”
How is scrambled eggs your specialty?
I’m instantly reminded of this one line
in the book, where Paul is critical of her
cooking.
“...everything she cooked came out tasting
strangely industrial, as if years of eating
in hospital cafeterias had somehow corrupted
any culinary talent she might once have had.”
Not long after, she has her first explosive
episode, after reading about Misery’s death
at the end of the final book.
She leaves to go away to her laughing place,
but before going, tells Paul,
“You better hope nothing happens to me,
because if I die,
you die.”
I feel like I’ve heard that somewhere before.
“I think you missed the part that if he
dies… you die.”
Not quite, but pretty close.
Paul sneaks out of the room and nearly breaks
a ceramic penguin, which is actually more
of a recurring symbol in the book, where Annie
uses it as an example when she says she knows
that Paul's been out of his room, the cops look
at it while inspecting the house in the summer,
and near the very end, he actually throws
it through the parlor window to get their
attention.
He also discovers a shrine dedicated to…
none other than himself, where Annie has a
signed photo and each of the nine Misery books,
with two copies of the first eight.
As someone who has certain movies on both
DVD and Blu-Ray and probably will get 4Ks
in the future, I can kind of relate.
He also snoops around in the kitchen, where
if you’re paying attention you may see another
connection to the book, in the form of this
calendar that is still stuck on February,
because Annie keeps forgetting to turn the
pages.
In the novel it’s in the guestroom Paul
is staying at, where it serves as a by-product
of her deteriorating mental state, but I guess
it’s in the kitchen for the film.
One of the reasons that Paul snuck out of
the room was to get more medication, and he
has a plan for what he wants to do with it.
He empties the capsules into a small pocket
he folds using a pieces of notebook paper,
and tries to poison Annie with it at dinner.
In the scene where he’s emptying out the
capsules, we see this strange camera angle.
I think this is Annie’s point of view.
There’s a part in the book where she looks
in through the keyhole, and that’s what
I think is going on here and maybe the reason
she knocks over the glass of wine in the dinner
scene is actually no accident.
After refilling the glass, they toast to the
return of the Misery character, and in the
days that follow, Paul gets down to work on
writing the novel.
If you look at the pages in the typewriter,
many of them are actually accurate to the
text in the book.
To be perfectly clear, Misery by Stephen King
has certain chapters that are just excerpts
from Misery’s Return by Paul Sheldon, and
the text in the typewriter is often word for
word.
There are a couple of deviations, like this
part, which corresponds to page 169, but with
an added paragraph to account for the name
change in the movie, where Geoffrey is now
known as Windthorne.
I do not know the reason for this change though.
Then there’s this shot, where the top paragraph
is pulled from page 168, but the bottom paragraph
is new text, which says “As the flames crept
ever higher, Misery realized that only she
stood betwee…” something…
I wonder if this was added as a foreshadowing
of the ending of the movie, where Misery is
actually in flames, literally because Paul
burns the book, whereas in the novel he hides
the real Misery’s Return and burns a blank
stack of pages to hit Annie where it hurts
most.
*SCREAMING*
But as Paul progresses with the book, Annie
realizes that her time with Paul can’t last
forever, and falls into a depressive episode.
That night, we see an exterior of the house
during a thunderstorm.
The camera is crooked.
This is called a dutch angle, and in this
case, it’s used to signal Annie is off balance
mentally.
“You’re a beautiful, brilliant, famous
man of the world, and I’m not a movie star type."
Says Kathy Bates, the woman who would win
an Oscar for this role.
"Kathy Bates in Misery."
"I would like to thank Jimmy Caan.
and apologize publicly for the ankles."
Annie decides to go away again, and Paul sneaks
out of the room again, where he finds Annie’s
scrap book, and while these newspaper articles
documenting her life aren’t as reference-heavy
as I’d hoped, there is still info we can
pull from them.
Like for example, if the movie feels like
it covers a shorter timespan than the book
it’s because it does.
The article claims that Paul’s vehicle was
found after 1 week, and this is not long before
the end of the movie at this point, so the
whole time he was at Annie’s in the movie
really only seems to cover a few weeks, maybe
a month, whereas in the novel he’s in captivity
for 5 months.
This is one of the many examples of the movie
just being so much more tame and toned down.
One movie change that I did like, which really
makes Annie that much scarier as an antagonist
is this detail.
It says she’s was a valedictorian in high
school and graduated nursing school as a Magna
Cum Laude, meaning her grade point average
was almost perfect.
So in addition to being this big, forceful
person she’s also very clever, and with
two broken legs, Paul’s only real hope is
to outsmart her in order to escape his situation.
As you know if you watch my channel, I love
a good psychological battle in a horror movie.
Another movie difference is that we actually
see the police chief trying to find him, rather
than just seeing everything from Paul’s
perspective.
And he even has a little desk cowboy dressed
exactly like him.
I wish I had a little desk cowboy version of me...
At some point the Colorado State Police get
involved in searching for Paul, and
Buster ends up on the helicopter to see if
he can spot anything out of the ordinary.
Now Misery is a very Hitchcockian horror film,
in particular, it’s very similar to Alfred
Hitchcock’s 1954 film Rear Window, where
the main character is also confined to a single
room after breaking his leg.
Hitchcock was known for almost always making
a cameo appearance in his movies, so Misery
director Rob Reiner decided to do the same,
though he is very hard to identify in his
appearance as the helicopter pilot.
Hitchcock would not be the only legendary
director that Reiner took inspiration from,
there was also influence from Stanley Kubrick.
At the end of Misery, we see Paul again 18
months later, and he’s finished a new novel
called The Higher Education of J Phillip Stone.
Gotta wonder if this has anything to do Philip
Stone, an actor who often worked with Kubrick
and appeared in Barry Lyndon, A Clockwork
Orange and of perhaps most notably, The Shining.
He’s the guy who tells Jack to “correct
them.”
“But I… ‘corrected’ them sir.”
If that one seems like a stretch, keep in
mind that at the time, there were only two
Stephen King novels that took place in his
fictional town of Sidewinder, Colorado, and
those two were Misery and The Shining.
Let’s move on to the finale.
“Remember how for all those years how nobody
knew who Misery’s real father was, or if
they’d ever be reunited?
It’s all right here.”
This is an actual plot point in Misery’s
Return, the book within the Stephen King book,
but it happens much earlier, at the start
of what I assume is basically the second act
-- not at the end, like movie Paul writes
it out.
Eventually, Paul finished it when he knocks
her out with the pig ornament, and this is
symbolic because the pig represents Misery.
Annie has an actual pig of her own named Misery,
which Paul doesn’t like because he thought
he was done writing Misery novels, so he ends
up using Misery against her to finally do
away with his captor.
There’s an interesting scene at the end,
where Annie reappears 18 months later while
Paul is at lunch with his editor, but it turns
out to just be in his imagination because
of the PTSD he acquired while staying with
her.
This is meant to be kind of similar to the
book, where we’re given the impression that
Annie survived and ambushed him at this apartment,
but that turns out to just be a writer’s
scenario; it’s not really clear if he imagined
it because of the PTSD or if he was just letting
his mind wander and write out a worst case
scenario type of scene.
That part in the movie does a good job of
recreating that dynamic, because when Paul
sees her, he doesn’t panic, and it just
takes him a moment to concentrate and convince
himself that it’s not really Annie.
Because he knows that she's dead.
Also, the name of the woman who played the
waitress is Wendy Bowers.
How great is that?
It’s like Wendy Torrance meets Henry Bowers.
And she claims to be his #1 fan.
As the credits roll, we hear the Liberace
song, “I’ll Be Seeing You.”
You may remember that Liberace was Annie’s
favorite musician.
Annie Wilkes is the embodiment of the toxic
fan, which has become an even bigger topic
of discussion in the years since Misery’s
release, so join me in the next episode of
Horror History where I’ll be analysing the
entire history of Annie Wilkes.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one, assuming we stay inside.